the Louisiana Police are investigating
the mysterious death of a beloved civil
rights activists in Baton Rouge's black
community the body of 75 year old Sadie
Roberts Joseph was found in the trunk of
a car on Friday not far from the History
Museum that she founded almost two
decades ago CTM national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is outside the museum and
Baton Rouge with more on this story
tareka this is so shocking she's 75 in
the trunk of a car this does not sound
random at all how was the community
reacting the community is heartbroken
and as you mentioned just how she was
found is what makes it even more eerie
but this museum was her pride and joy
it's small it's colorful it's currently
boarded up but it played a major role in
this community a lot of people have
stories about Miss Roberts Sadie Roberts
and she said things like you know
education is important Nelson Mandela
quote behind us she also talked about
the importance of education right now
police say they are not calling this a
murder but they're asking for anyone
with information to help them Sadie
Roberts Josif was a tireless advocate
for peace in her Baton Rouge community
city leaders say the museum she founded
was designed to bring the past to life
to embrace our history to learn about a
path
and to be able to move forward in Eugene
on Friday police say Roberts Joseph's
body was found in the trunk of a car
located on a residential street about
three miles from her home and some two
miles from her museum authorities have
not said how she died or who owns the
car in an online post that Baton Rouge
Police Department paid tribute to
Robert's Joseph calling her a treasure
to our community and adding detectives
are working diligently to bring the
person or persons responsible for this
heinous act to justice this particular
crime on this particular individual left
me empty state representative see Denise
Marcel posted a remembrance on Facebook
calling Robert's Joseph an amazing woman
who loved her history she wanted to show
you your history she wanted you to touch
your history she wanted you to feel your
history Roberts Joseph recently hosted
the city's annual Juneteenth celebration
commemorating the emancipation of slaves
in the south she also founded a local
organization aimed at combating drugs
and violence Baton Rouge mayor President
Sharon Westin Broome says her commitment
to the cultural and educational fabric
of our community is beyond description
those who loved her hope her legacy will
live on embrace diversity learn about
history
that's the only way we're gonna be able
to heal Roberts Joseph was known and
quoted for saying things like if you
don't know where you come from you don't
know where you're going the mayor has
offered a $5,000 cash reward for any
information leading to an arrest and
indictment Anthony no she's clearly left
a strong legacy but that's a that is a
big mystery there Jericka thank you I
think I don't know how a body found in a
car is not called a murderer well I know
there's more to the story but it's very
yes certainly looks that way